but a little bit earlier in the show I
mentioned Paul Pelosi tonight there's
more confusion about what happened
inside Nancy Pelosi's house on October
28th now if you remember that's when
nudist a nudist named David depap
attacked Paul Pelosi with a hammer now
according to a Federal indictment by the
federal department of justice police
officers opened the door to Nancy
Pelosi's home now this is fascinating
because it's in direct contradiction to
the filings by San Francisco district
attorney and local law enforcement who
say that no in fact Paul Pelosi opened
the door an in business C news affiliate
in the Bay Area just reported that
according to law enforcement sources who
saw body cam footage the D.A is right
the doj is wrong Paul Pelosi opened the
door now why is this important because
asking for details or facts when it
comes to this story have again been
dismissed as a conspiracy as an entire
narrative that David depap was an
insurrectionist and a Maga Republican
was built no questions that could get in
the way of that narrative for example
this isn't the first time that NBC News
contradicted The doj's Narrative earlier
this month NBC ran this report which
stated that Paul Pelosi didn't think he
was in danger when David depap was in
his home
sources familiar with what unfolded in
the Pelosi residents now revealing when
officers responded to the high priority
call they were seemingly unaware they'd
been called to the home of the speaker
of the house after a knock and announce
the front door was opened by Mr Pelosi
the 82 year old did not immediately
declare an emergency or tried to leave
his home but instead began walking
several feet back into the foyer toward
the assailant and away from police why
Pelosi didn't try to flee or tell
responding officers he was in distress
is unclear we still don't know exactly
what unfolded between Mr Pelosi and the
suspect for the 30 minutes they were
alone inside that house before police
arrived now that report by NBC news that
seems to at least be in part supported
by the new investigative report from an
NBC affiliate in the Bay Area was
totally scrubbed from its website they
also suspended that reporter Miguel
almagor he has not been heard from no
tweets no appearances on television for
almost two weeks NBC claims that Al
Maguire violated their standards
what standards were those
see no NBC reporters were ever suspended
for the lies that they told in helping
the Democratic party watch
right-wing media has been focused on
Hunter Biden this laptop that
intelligence officials have warned or is
likely Russian disinformation the story
is preposterous right the story is
preposters so we're supposed to believe
that Hunter Biden and a drunken stupor
dropped off his laptop and I guess
apparently Q Anon repair office it is so
obviously a Russian operation this looks
like Russian intelligence this Walks
Like Russian intelligence this talks
like Russian intelligence this effort by
Giuliani and the New York Post and and
Steve Bannon to cook up uh supposed dirt
on Joe Biden looks like a classic
Russian Playbook disinformation campaign
that all of those lies all of that
misinformation was apparently up to NBC
standards this report that we now know
or suggest is true below NBC standards
you can see them on the screen he's Buck
sex and he's the host of The Clay Travis
and Buck Sexton show and he joins us now
Buck's also a former CIA Officer Buck
help me make sense of this what's going
on
well you know will I think it's pretty
straightforward this is yet again the
American people being shown what the
rules of so-called journalism are liars
get pulitzers and Truth tellers get
fired or in this case suspended because
it's all about activism it's all about
support of the partisan narrative in the
moment I mean that's a Former
Intelligence officer watching those
clips of people saying that the hunter
Biden laptop was Russian disinformation
there's not much left of the Intel
Community these days in terms of
reputation to protect but they were
certainly trying to destroy it there and
they did a good job of it we see this
time and time again where Even If
eventually the truth comes out there's
no punishment I mean we didn't even get
into Russia collusion for example where
the entire Democrat aligned corporate
media spent four years they still say
it's kind of true in some ways you ask
them how they don't really ever explain
it but will they understand that these
are actually the rules this is what we
are dealing with this is not a bug this
is a feature this is the desire of the
Democrats to use the biggest me media
Outlets they possibly can to tell the
most important lies the biggest lies or
even just suppress the truth in moments
of peril for their power and we saw that
with a hunter Biden laptop and with the
Nancy Pelosi story I would just point
out Paul Pelosi's Story the security
situation alone is worthy of a serious
debuff how is it that this guy if he was
invited in or wasn't invited in was able
to attack Nancy Pelosi's husband the
police response all of this should be
something that journalists want to know
right away but they're trying to slow
walk this because they know that there
was a story to tell at the time to help
Democrats in an election and that was
all that mattered
there was a story to tell are you
referencing their Buck the entire
narrative this is ornate narrative that
was built upon a foundation that David
depap was a Maga Republican somehow
therefore this is connected to January
6th that was the narrative that was
built with very few facts to support it
underneath and now we understand that if
you ask for facts facts which are now
coming forward to try to clarify what is
the story you're guilty of conspiracy no
need to make an affirmative case right
simply questioning the facts makes you
guilty of a conspiracy yeah what you've
seen here well is that they will
actually weaponize the most basic
principles of fact-finding and what's
supposedly journalism against people you
ask the question and you're the bad guy
and we just saw in the horrific tragedy
of Uvalde for example police initially
were lying the reports initially were
entirely false and there was a reason
for that right there were people who
were trying to cover up for their
entirely inadequate and honestly awful
response so in this instance you just
want to say well why can't we know the
truth if it's so straightforward if it's
such an obvious story why are there two
law enforcement agencies that have
different facts that's just a reality
they can say that it's Q Anon or
conspiracy or lunacy but how about just
the truth but well we all know they
didn't want that before the election and
they're not going to want it on this
issue for a long time someone's going to
need to get that body cam footage the
local D.A and that local affiliate in
San Francisco on the same page because
their facts are getting in the way of
the previously built narrative Buck
always great to talk to you thanks for
being with me tonight thanks my friend
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight